what seems to be happening is what the
left
i would say predicted but i think really
promised is a better word
the left promised us that trump was
going to win the election on election
day
but then they were going to somehow come
out winning the vote later on
they were going to call it they called
it a red mirage the mirage is all the
people are going to vote for you and
you're going to see it with your own
eyes
but then don't worry later on we're
going to win they all seem so confident
don't you worry we're going to win
here is msnbc's joy reid discussing how
the red mirage turns out
and i think partly because even though
we knew the red wave was a thing and
then
the red mirage i should say the red
mirage we all knew it was coming
but went you're right in the moment it
is it's enervating
it's it's aggravating and i think partly
and i said this last night i do think
it's because
we've been reporting for five years
rachel about
russia about national security you know
just
just undermining our national security
you know the impeachment
of the racism the nazis all of it
and then coveted laying on top of it
felt like a repudiation was coming
and i think even though we
intellectually understand what america
is at its base right
that there is a great amount of racism
anti-blackness
anti-wokeness this idea that political
correctness is some sort of
scheme to destroy white america right
like we know what this country is
but you still part of you i think part
of your your heart says you know what
maybe the country is gonna
pay pay off all of this pain the
children were stolen
with a repudiation so you hear first of
all how much the left despises this
country
just the way they speak we know what
this country is we know what it is it's
awful and
you know what they've got to do they've
got to vote for democrats to pay off the
pain and injustice of this country
lady give me a break it's the greatest
country on earth
this woman is spouting her stupid
nonsense on tv she's extremely wealthy
she's treated extremely well she's
treated better by the law
than people basically any country on
earth
give me a break lady
but this is what they think the left
hates the country i don't know how else
to put it i know
it sounds extreme but she just said it
you heard it with her own ears she goes
this country
they've got to pay off all the pain and
the damage and the injustice they've
caused
no no the country doesn't have to pay
off anything lady it's the best country
on earth get over yourself i'm sorry
that you're upset about some imaginary
problem
while you pontificate on television and
count your stacks of money
but and and feel safe in your personhood
and your property
and in your political liberties i'm
sorry that you're that upsets you
where else would you like to go what's
what country is better off give me a
break
but they don't like the country and you
heard at the top you heard at the top
she says
we have a red mirage we knew it was
going to come the red mirage had to come
and then the
red mirage is coming i think she
believes this i think this is a
self-fulfilling prophecy
i i think this is an article of faith
for the left
you always hear the left talking about
how we have to defend democracy but it's
ironic because the democrats are the
people who most undermine democracy
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts